how's it going Rosen brooder name's
Pierre back and then welcome back to
some battles discovery in the last
episode we had a lot of jump scares
I just wouldn't stop and I hurt my legs
oh man I should action oh [ __ ] I forgot
to get a pillow but apparently you're
supposed to use the chipper in here
I'm a genius I then not I did not like I
did not do that ah I got the key total
your jump scares
this is jump scares whoever made this
likes jump scare hello so many people
are debating like jump scares aren't
true true fear it should remember I
think just the same but if it's only
jump scares and it's I don't know you
get more jump scared if you are if the
mood is set like some people say that
you know there's no mood oh wait I was
supposed to use two key there mmm yes
I'm such a genius
don't try to laugh it off it's mixing
like it let's go to the day I'm the
brain like when you haircut I don't like
I hate getting haircuts ah whatever
I'm not a girl I don't I don't talk
about myself like me okay so yeah we're
in here
oh [ __ ] hold on I need to turn on the
volume it's so freaking loud hello
epic music I expect something bad to
happen no I'm just corridors this is how
it is ah oh look at that guy what is he
doing mister oh yeah
is going on here what is he doing with
that thing it's an anchor no you don't
know you don't have [ __ ] huh okay I
don't trust this thing why is he talking
to me go here maybe I love that son
get away oh man oh you should have gone
away holy [ __ ]
red light never good news oh [ __ ] nope
ha ha ha no no no I know what's gonna
happen
I've seen these many I've experienced
this many times I'm an Iron Maiden next
bye now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go over here we're not gonna say
hello - I know I'm not but through [ __ ]
I just have to oh okay just
date so think it's the ha ha
holy [ __ ] nothing happened Oh Oh what
the [ __ ] I went through the wall holy
[ __ ] that wasn't me
oh man they [ __ ] tricked me okay
let's go over here ah barrels I knew the
barrels did it I hate that house so much
like my hatred for battles it will gross
everything
[ __ ] you barrels really raro I wish I
had stuff no [ __ ] Irish had so far no
but [ __ ] [ __ ] is busy uh uh [ __ ]
bells back where I hate barrels is why I
hate them what is this anyway okay we're
good okay so we're gonna fill this
actually we already got where you're
Sonic
uh thank you can closet there's
something in here it's very attractive
but you are staying in the class that
could I our mouse but we got nothing
here oh yeah we got a bear socks it's
good
Ed's get all is well everything is
fantastic let's use the key it's the
wrong key
let's use this I got I saw that by
myself I think I'm pretty impressive
sometimes I'm afraid him good impression
ater that's a word find another key look
at me I'm doing progress are you jelly
you jelly are you jealous of chair huh
get me up huh Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no it's ed
just seen monster [ __ ] his dick is so
big have you seen his dick
I'm not joking it's [ __ ] huge
it's getting it let's try and get a look
at it it's Nick
ah
ah [ __ ] so where do I go actually I
don't want to see a stick
singing stick means you die is that you
warm I dig I kill you I kill you I bet
that is why I kill you you live in my
dick you look my balls I look at my ball
well Oh [ __ ] barrels oh eight [ __ ]
barrels ah pals right yeah yeah bro bro
oh crap run ever
I can't even move it ah ah hi I'm
getting you though I'm getting you [ __ ]
you barrels really [ __ ] you
so now what we just have a bunch of
[ __ ] keys in the mayor sonic I don't
understand
and I
where's he going what are you doing oh
oh I get it I get it I get it now you
are coming with me mr. Shawn I must stop
huh what the [ __ ] man Oh
ah ouch dumb um freakin stop what your
bad replacement for Stefano I think you
are too actually
why it's a [ __ ] pad oh we're sonic
maybe yes
I'm such a genius yes yes where I am is
a stone stone mr. stone I know you're
upset because I called you a bad Stefano
copy but we need to collaborate there
stones everywhere you are replaceable oh
man
oh [ __ ] man ah I saw his penis it was
freaking huge oh oh
Oh
ah [ __ ] give me a [ __ ] break no oh we
good we're actually good it's good the
bro is a pro per day thank you bro I
would Proficy if you were here but
actually I know I would run away and
scream like me but whatever is no it's a
[ __ ] lab it's not so fun oh you got a
shell so fun ah it's like the perfect
place for hi Stefano Stefano seriously
don't worry hiding so no it's not cool
in the box
see so though Stefano someone should
make us ofon ohseong I know you know the
I made the little food Freud bring it
away a song he's working I see said he's
working on one but he's like super good
so I'm guessing he's gonna take his time
but anyway it's the found a dubstep
mm-hmm it's a problem I won't here to
sivanna shirt actually have like shares
you're a good share buddy a good share
I'm sorry if I scream it don't you let's
go in here this room is faculty to
familiar I seen this guy and this guy
has a small penis but the monster no he
has a huge thing hmm Oh
skulls I'm sorry Scully but you scared
me scared me to learn eyes okay buddy I
understand
and
so yeah we are at done privacy room
pretty cozy room actually I could
totally she'll here like read books
touch that guy's penis no I wouldn't do
that a monkey
ah no hey 1658 Jane or night further
disappointments the antiquaries ladies
finding yielded and stuff okay
bunch of stuff gotta love stuff some
things but seriously though what are we
doing a hey everybody tell me don't give
me that look
come on by talk to me
he wasn't taught why
what either yeah it's exacting room with
the paintings and paintings really you
are a very nice chair buddy thank you
almost said Felix good one he was really
lazy when he made this I think mmm
oh now I don't know where to go is it's
a broken window part again it could be
yeah prochniak is let's use one of a
good chair hello Petey I am sure how you
all do you want me to throw you all
right your shells you're not gonna do
that you're not gonna throw me I'm sorry
check aah I'm sorry I thought I would
worry super disappointing now look I can
totally see outside the council and
there's totally a tuna box here come on
shared my right with me right yeah okay
sure what does not want to collaborate
all right sure
seriously though huh don't you hide from
me in the window uh don't don't fight me
Cherie ah [ __ ] not even the shares are
collaborating where the [ __ ] am I going
there we go maybe it's a painting
it's always a painting no it's not the
bank give me check in here
it's like but we have a key mmm yeah we
have another king mmm we the way you're
telling and not with something we are
stuck in this place in this well well I
Stefano I don't know I'm a [ __ ]
walking paradox no I'm not
threesomes with a [ __ ] Triceratops
the Reptar rap demands are mocking deaf
rockstars wearing synthetic wigs made of
an wash did I have my [ __ ] legs